Hallo Emily, das ist Sammy und ich habe drei
Fragen an dich. Die erste ist,
wer deine musikalischen Inspirationen sind, als
du ein Kind warst, welcher Sänger hat dich am meisten inspiriert,
und die dritte Frage wäre,
welches Lied du als Kind am meisten gesungen hast
Hoffentlich beantwortest du
alle meine Fragen und hast Spaß mit dem
Interview, also pass auf dich auf, aber ich bin definitiv
in einem Haus aufgewachsen, in dem alle
Klassiker gespielt wurden. Ich habe eine
Menge Käfer und Bowie und Peter
Frampton und Affen und ähm gehört  Oh Gott,
alle hören sich viele gute Sachen an,
Hendrix wurde hauptsächlich im Zimmer meines Bruders gespielt
und eigentlich auch viel REM in dir.
Ich brauchte viel YouTube, als ich
aufwuchs, sie waren groß und dann die 90er
Stiller, ähm, mein Produzent arbeitete tatsächlich
an einem  Sie aufzuzeichnen, wie cool es ist, dass sich der Kreis schließt,
ähm, aber ich fühle
mich gut, das hat mir wirklich geholfen,
weil ich diese schöne unterstützende
Basis der Originalmusik hatte, von der Sie wissen, dass
meine Eltern früher zugehört haben, und so fühle ich
mich jetzt  Heutzutage gibt es jede Menge von
DJs, die Songs remixen, von denen Sie wissen, dass
Sie diese Songs hören, und
ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich das schon einmal gehört habe
, und es ist so, als hätten
Helden der Schießschule einen Supertramp-Song gesampelt,
und niemand weiß das wirklich  Es ist
eigentlich ein Supertramp-Song, den ich liebe
, und ich fühle mich, als wäre ich immer
die Person im Auto
, wenn meine Freunde sagen, oh mein Gott, das ist dieser eine
Radiohead-Song, der so tut, als wäre er
eigentlich nicht, oder das ist dieser eine Bowie-
Song, den ich liebe  dass Sie wissen, dass
ich tatsächlich einen Song auf meiner Platte
habe, der für ihn irgendwie ein Nein Maj ist, lass uns
Freunde sein, damit wir erkennen können, dass es so etwas
wie Wham Bam ist, danke, Ma'am, ein
bisschen total ein Witz, nicht autobiografisch
in die falsche
richtung gefahren manchmal soll es
lustig sein aber äh ja musik aufwachsen
immer wichtig musik auch heute noch sehr
wichtig